[Music]
magic
both beautiful and powerful binds
together our long history
that common bond we share is the legacy
of hogwarts
[Applause]
[Music]
now it is time to add your own story to
these hallowed halls
and quite possibly shape the future
of the wizarding world
every corridor every portrait
every stone in this castle tells the
story
witches and wizards who came before
here you will meet lifelong friends and
grow into your own
magical abilities in the classrooms of
the world's most
talented professors and while your
journey begins at hogwarts
brewing potions taming fantastic beasts
and mastery spells there is a larger
world beyond these walls
a world filled with dangers you can't
yet imagine
an ancient knowledge long gone from this
world
that strange and mysterious talent you
possess
may be the key to unlocking this
dormant power
your potential
is limitless
[Music]
but what form will it take
the journey ahead will reveal
what you stand for
[Music]
the choices you make now
[Music]
will define the legacy of hogwarts